so my body is gonna move you know in a
health fashion organized fashion and to
shift my weight the right way my weight
shifts the right way I have some hip
torque Keynesian historic okay so when I
do this when I go to sort it's not going
to be a shoulder exercise you know hold
everything
hold hold the posture breathe in
generate that swell
[Music]
have a percussiveness to the end with
your breath and your flexion same with
your timing everything hits there move
the sword with that organization so when
I pick up the sword I'm not doing that
my body's picking it up okay let's try
this
[Music]
the cultivation angle the angle that's
going to give you that strength and
structural integrity power everyone I
can't let the sort go dead so the sword
angle is going to be at that 45 degree
angle that's also your ideal angle for
deflection this isn't this is going to
be weak
okay so one night when I moved the
weapon I'm going to harmonize with that
angle that angle is my good kid okay I
don't do whatever I do what I have to do
to meet that angle so as as I move I
keep that angle you see that I don't
bring the sword around me you see that
difference well once you bring the sword
around your upper body your shoulders
upper chest is now independent of the
structure okay I don't know if it's
visible but then things moving on top
versus my body moving as a unit okay so
keep that angle bring the sword up with
the angle keep the angle and move into
that angle and so in a way this sword is
very much to me like muted audio she
right this part there so the Western is
going around me you see that and there's
a space werewolves IQ goes step and let
it pass me I don't have to do anything
with my hands okay so if you watch the
back end of the weapon you see you're
like it's coming at me well that's when
I have to move okay so I pick up the
weapon
that will help you stop any excessive
hand releasing that you have to do to
stay in connection with your sword so
when you're shallow like this you see
you have to do what you what if that it
has to do with Naga right you got to
open up your grip because you're not in
connection with a centre to centre so my
grip is loose when I'm training but I
don't come off this stores not fighting
my fingers so
[Music]
okay let's go you're fighting that sort
it's wrestling out of your bridge so you
got it figure it out
no don't spin your hands at the top it's
not a propeller hat no the body does the
movement you're dropping it you're
dropping it in the back you're dropping
that you're losing at 45-degree angle on
the back lower yourselves lower is
always better stop being comfortable
that's why you don't bend your knees
your strictures broken hold it tight
hold it tight I can't do it with a
sunken chest lower lower let's think eat
more dancing one percussive ending
[Music]
parallel to the ground
chest up you're still wrestling with it
though you're spinning it at the top
you're spinning it at the top lower
don't lose the back 45 don't lose the
back 45 good blend with the weapon very
loose not organized not percussive not
percussive okay so some things I want to
try to avoid I don't want is it not an
object right yes
is it not subject to inertia gravity
evil medicine yes the same thing right
center of gravity line of gravity I have
to blend with with the weapon you guys
understand that concept
okay it's not this thing that I'm
holding at the end of my wrist and it
has nothing to do with me I'm trying to
find this same Fukunaga dynamic that
same center to center connection that
same musubi so when I do certain things
so I want to pick up the sword and
there's nothing in my body I just move
my arms do you see that so you going
like this you're not you're not going
like this see the digits the sword is
the sword tip going up yes the sword tip
is going up my body's moving it
not my body thing still in my hands move
it you get that crushing all the time in
body alright okay you're not moving your
body you're not moving your body you're
just moving your eyes same exact thing
so here in this case I'm picking up I'm
dropping the tip it is true but my hands
aren't they so my hands had to be picked
up by my Center being picked up not by
my my sword dropping and my centerline
staying still no so but there's a
flexion that happens at the beginning
can you see the swelling and it moves
them it moves the weapon it's not just
in hand okay I have to inhale it away
boom that like that uh and I reinforced
so you're just gonna boom right so I
that's the same inhaling that I'm doing
here okay I'm starting the movement I'm
inhaling to get that swell going that's
what it kicks up my hands then the sword
tip I let fall because my hands came up
the sword tip wants to fall I don't make
it fall you see that difference I let it
fall so I pick up my hand and the sword
starts to fall but you can see how
relaxed my hands are they're letting it
happen not aiming it to happen let it
happen and we're gonna exaggerate my
hand so you can tell how I'm not using
my hands and arms so go to the weapon
now as I start to step right I'm gonna
get underneath it just like okay you
don't need your weapon
just like you get it when I'm really
good underneath him boom I'm trying to
get my spinner underneath him right if
I'm doing each go along on me it's the
same thing Center underneath him I don't
go on the side do you guys see that
same exactly so swell let the sword drop
and then I gotta get underneath it and
once I start that underneath it that
tips going to want to go more do you
understand
and as the tip wants to go more it's not
going to go more and go that way
it's gonna go more and go which way but
I'm not making it go back it's going
back so swell right let it just start
open get underneath it and beat it you
see that so I've never spun the weapon
behind me do you guys understand okay
some of you are not doing it you go like
this can you see that difference that's
what I call that beanie boy thing
because when I grew up right
porky on the little Rosco's used to wear
a beanie boy had a little hat ahead of
propeller on it and you guys are making
the sword look like a propeller to me so
instead it's an XP can let it drop once
I get underneath it and move forward I
know it's gonna want to do that and once
I move forward to keep my grip and I
hold this end you see it's going like
this and I stop this in and moving it's
gonna let me go back the other way do
you guys understand I did not swing my
arms so you can see yeah it wants to go
that way I just have to be there at the
right time
meaning that right when he gets behind
me boom my weight has to be on the end
of the sukkah then it'll start to move
different it's just a dance
now I'm gonna exaggerate in that way and
go all the way to the back it's going
that way and you will go forward the
same thing okay let's try and get that
going
[Music]
take your time each rep do less with the
sword more with the body less with the
sword more with the body form not power
power comes from forms find the form
first speed comes from forms tasks
yourself
[Music]
now I get the sword going and now it has
to stop okay do I stop it no I don't
stop this Lee the shortstop
so remember because I got it going here
for mine from my weight pulling it on
there
it starts to go back then gravity takes
over it wants to drop but it wants to
spin do you guys see that it wants to
spin so since they used to do this thing
where you go boom and you let them go
can't go to go flying across the than
that so I need to do entertain you
picture it okay cool
because he almost hit someone once if
you dope it another time okay so as I
come around as it wants to spin all the
way that I keep the sword tip from
dropping is not by slowing it down but
by putting my weight on the back end
at that moment your does an boom that's
where you have your coke cube percussion
oh oh
versus this angle stuff we see all the
time so each rip at the bottom of the
cut I'm I'm practicing that save
percussion weight dropping own
relaxation doing less not more okay so
I'm gonna get all the way to the end and
it's on the back foot boom what we tend
to see is you start slowing it down
and then you have all that isolation
separation in the upper body so as I
move boom I'm hitting the bottom you can
see if my hands hit the bottom then the
sort tip doesn't drop that's very
different from this where you let it
drop and it's very different from this
where you're trying to slow it down as
you go I want the opposite effect I want
to hit that suka so hard boom that it
shakes on the back foot not after you
want to think of it more as as a
separate weight exercise hey you're
standing here hey stand over here spoon
drop your way
[Music]
hey let's try
feel your midsection swollen lock
organized your four corners united your
center low less with the book in war
with the body dance with the weapon
don't swing it
[Music]
you have to breathe out you have to have
a percussive breath during training
[Music]
much better third Lane fill it up
feel the weapon go round you don't make
it go around you set your body up so it
dances that last swing was totally
conscious movement that's not good
so step so you're not twisting your body
step so you're not your body's not
twisted guy belching you can't just step
wherever it's just like dancing you step
the wrong place you're gonna mess your
partner up
[Music]
my time and space step where you need to
step at the right time you need to stab
fill this third Lane up don't be afraid
if you break the scores because you're
cutting wrong isn't it
[Music]
more locked up lace more locked up way
to be to GUI remember when he hit me
there's attention in the extension of
filling it's not soft and mushy
[Music]
you're tilting your head stop tilting
your head
[Music]
lower lower lower move lower get the hip
rotation we didn't even cover it but the
first demonstration but it's in there
you want that lateral torquing you want
that hip corner power a lot of you guys
are just stepping straight with no
torquing at all that's leaving a huge
part of the conditioning off you want
that lateral tension you're swinging
that sword around you you're asking too
much of the sword just like it okay you
can't add that you can't run all the way
around your right that's goofy you're
asking too much so don't take such a
side angle on your cut just off the line
the line is the width of your sword so
you don't need to pull that back hip
right boo feet off the line you're gonna
ask too much of this movement
[Music]
you're clearing the line too much that
that's why you have to swing the sword
around on the on your own with your
hands too much it's too much clearing it
too much
don't cut so much side-to-side watch
your head tilt it's already a habit got
it Maya
breathe in breathe in breathe out
Priscilla breathe in breathe out breathe
in breathe out that 90 is important
[Music]
so you step too far to the outside on
that last one shot and you got all
twisted up
make every rap count every rep every
reps your last rep when you're in the
lane you own the lane so don't let that
back person push you forward you got no
excuse for blurring through a rap
[Music]